[Music]
Robert Spencer here for jihad watch a
program of the David Horowitz Freedom
Center and for the Center for Security
Policy or well stop police and the
enforcers of China's Cultural Revolution
at nothing on today's social justice
warriors one of their latest targets for
self-recrimination and re-education is
CJ nitkowski a former major league
baseball pitcher and now a broadcaster
for the Texas Rangers Nikau skis crime
retweeting a tweet from the proud boys
which describes itself as a pro-western
fraternal organization for men who
refused to apologize for creating the
modern world
aka Western chauvinists proud boys
declares anti racism as one of its
values and it's clear that nitkowski
doesn't know anything about the proud
boys but that didn't stop the guardians
of acceptable opinion from coming after
him mikowski according to sports day
deleted his tweets and protected his
account after being accused of a racist
attitude for a liking of all things a
tweeted photo of the gold medal-winning
US Olympic women's hockey team that's
right it was not a photo of Klansmen and
robes and hoods or goose-stepping Nazis
with the caption I'm with them not even
a photo of the man that the left would
have us believe that every decent person
hates mr. Donald J Trump no it was a
photo of the gold medal winning US
Olympic women's hockey team but sports
day went on to inform us that it wasn't
the photo that caused the controversy
but the account that sent the tweet the
account proud boys USA has been labeled
an extremist group by the Southern
Poverty Law Center even worse they went
on to say that the photo in question
shows the team celebrating its win with
an unidentified team member circled in
red in the picture making a circular
sign with two fingers and three others
extended in sports the sign is often
considered an inside gotcha joke but
it's also similar to one associated with
the white power movement now what is the
symbol associated with the white power
movement
it's the okay sign
which everyone from Barack Obama to
Nancy Pelosi has been photographed
making but which now in the mythology of
the left means white power especially
when it comes from groups such as the
proud boys on its page on the proud boys
the Southern Poverty Law Center claims
that their disavows of bigotry are
bolide by their actions and so Nick
Kowski had to be brought to heel never
mind that the SPLC is notorious for
defaming legitimate individuals and
groups by lumping them in with the likes
of the neo-nazis and the KKK never mind
that the SPLC refuses to list antifa a
genuine and violent hate group on a tape
group list which is notably short of
leftist organizations
never mind that clearly the SPLC itself
is a far left eight group dedicated to
destroying legitimate conservative
organizations as far as the
establishment media is concerned it's a
reliable source
and so nitkowski had to answer to the
thought police blindsided by all this at
Kowski obliged when he was asked to deny
that he was a white supremacist he
replied of course that's a given but
that never even crosses my mind that's
not how I was raised
I've just never had to prove that I'm
not racist I had no idea about this he
also issued an abject apology saying my
intention was simply to like a tweet of
a team photo of the gold medal winning
u.s. women's team I did not know the
group that posted the photo takes
positions on some issues that are
offensive to me and others I don't
endorse the group and have unfollowed
the account I apologize for not being
more careful on social media in turn and
in turn if I offended some of my
followers especially Rangers fans thus
far this groveling has placated the
slathering mob and Nick Kowski will keep
his job but you can be sure that if he
goes off the reservation again his
career will be over mass hysteria has
gripped the public sphere many times in
history the best analogy for what the
left is doing today is the Salem witch
trials the proud boys are witches as are
all those who descent from the leftist
agenda and they must be shunned by all
decent people CJ nitkowski is now
vehemently suspected of witchcraft
and we'll be on a short leash from now
until the day he dies this is all
happening in a land that professes to
protect and defend the freedom of speech
in Germany in 1933 Adolf Hitler was able
to dismantle the vemma Republic and
install a dictatorship within six months
of taking power I always thought that it
was so easy for him because Germany had
no strong traditions of democracy or
free speech but in America today we see
how easy it is for totalitarian speech
restrictions to descend upon a people
the American Left is empowered those who
are determined to implement Saul
Alinsky's 13th rule for radicals pick
the target freeze it personalize it and
polarize it cut off the support network
and isolate the target from sympathy go
after people and not institutions people
hurt faster than institutions the left
consistently does this makowsky is just
the latest to suffer from this tactic
the objective is to ensure that no one
ever in any walk of life and under any
circumstances dares to step out of line
and establishment conservatives unaware
of what is happening or not daring to be
targeted themselves have always
willingly played along allowing their
associations and allies to be dictated
by their enemies yet these cowardly
conservatives will not be spared what's
happening today to nitkowski will one
day happen to them this advancing beast
will devour everything and everyone in
its path until it is stopped but who has
the courage and the will to stop it I'm
Robert Spencer
[Music]